welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the fourth wall of the mcu has
come crashing down faster than the walls
of jen walters courtroom because
she-hulk as a series will stay true to
the comics by allowing this hero to go
meta and address the audience directly
staring deep into our souls the way i do
in these videos creepy right don't worry
this hypoallergenic ring means any
parasocial relationships will now go
unrequited and yes kiddos i'm back after
taking a week off to get married i still
have a job and that job is to
overanalyze why the producers of
she-hulk are describing jen's fourth
wall breaking as a superpower who jyn is
talking to and how this is all probably
setting the stage for deadpool yes
despite provost's teasiness with cameos
of wong and daredevil is our man wade
wilson waiting in the wings trailer
footage revealed what she-hulk's meta
humor would look like if you want to go
back to life as a lawyer i i respect
that
he doesn't mean that
and i propose to you that it's not jen
talking to us that's so weird about that
it's the fact that bruce could hear her
interviews with the cast and producers
at a press conference last week
confirmed that she-hulk would be
breaking the fourth wall like this
similar to deadpool and phoebe waller
bridge's amazing series fleabag but they
also correctly acknowledged that
she-hulk technically made these kind of
meta jokes in marvel comics years before
deadpool even existed really breaking
the fourth wall has always been part of
she-hulk's shtick however breaking the
fourth wall is truly a trope as old as
time from bugs bunny shorts to
shakespeare's soliloquies the term comes
from a theater convention in which an
audience sees a scene closed in by three
walls with an invisible fourth wall
between them in the stage that the
audience can see through sometimes
characters can break through this fourth
wall to address the audience directly
but that she-hulk press conference went
further to describe she-hulk's fourth
wall breaking head writer jessica gao
said quote it went through a lot of
evolutionary steps a long journey of how
much should she talk to camera is she
talking directly to the audience is
there another meta element is she
talking to somebody else that's more
behind the scenes and tatiana maslany
added quote i think that there's
something about she-hulk's awareness
where she's able to go from being jen to
she-hulk with a seamlessness her
consciousness stays the same and she's
aware of the audience that feels like
it's her superpower engaged with and i
think this is all super important to one
of the biggest mysteries about jen's
power set when bruce banner hulks out he
has to share his body with an alter ego
of the hulk until presumably when he
reached his smart hulk balanced stasis
that was when the bruce identity and the
hulk identity reached a kind of
agreement but when jen hulk's out from
the get-go she has no alternate identity
to wrestle with it's just her so why
doesn't jen have another personality i
think she does actually and i think it
is us or whoever she is talking to on
the other side of that fourth wall
barrier that's why it's very interesting
to hear the head writer raise this
question of who jen is actually talking
to this somebody else behind the scenes
it's a pretty unsettling notion when you
think about it especially when you
consider that unlike famous fourth wall
breakers like deadpool or zack morris
other characters notice she-hulk
breaking the reality he doesn't mean
that
this is a huge deal they mentioned
fleabag as an influence and if you watch
that series it's not that the main
character addresses the audience that's
not that weird really it's this one
significant moment in the second season
when andrew scott's character finally
notices her doing it and calls it out
he's been lying asking what is that
what
that thing that you're doing it's like
you disappear
what what are you not telling me
nothing tell me what's going on
underneath nothing tell me come on don't
tell me nothing
yeah isn't it pretty freaky when he
screams at the camera so similarly this
subtle turn of the head from bruce tells
us that this fourth wall breaking is not
just a convention structured into the
format of the she-hulk series it's a
behavior within the character's reality
from bruce's perspective jen
occasionally just looks off somewhere
and mutters to herself this also reminds
us of the other times in the mcu
characters have broken the fourth wall
to narrate the audience it's actually
pretty rare iron man 3 opened and closed
with tony stark talking to us directly a
famous man once said we create our own
demons who said that what does that even
mean doesn't matter i said it cause he
said it so now he was famous and
basically getting said by two well-known
guys
so if i were to wrap this up tie it with
a bow whatever my armor it was never a
distraction it was a cocoon but that
movie's post-credits team revealed that
tony was actually talking to an audience
in the movie the co-star of this series
bruce banner wow
i had no idea you're such a good
listener to be able to
share all my intimate thoughts and my
experiences with someone it just
cuts the weight of it in half you know
it's like a snake swallowing its own
tail everything comes full circle
and and the fact that you've been able
to help me process
so what were you with me it was yeah
we're we were at uh are you actively
napping i i was i i i drifted now call
me crazy but i like to unwind at the end
of the day with a cocktail or two i know
so weird right but get this i also like
to feel good when i wake up in the
morning
so weird right well you might think
those two things don't go together but
they actually do all you got to do is
start your night by drinking a z-biotics
z biotics is a probiotic drink that
breaks down a toxic byproduct of alcohol
called acetyl dehyde acetyldehyde acelde
it's that byproduct not dehydration that
makes martinis make for middling
mornings xebiotics is real science that
works just drink a zebiotics drink
responsibly pace yourself and you're
good to go and you know what i think i
want to party tonight so let's do this
now
hey call me crazy i just like being able
to unwind and feel good when i wake up
you should give it a try get 15 off your
first order of z biotics pre-alcohol
probiotic by clicking the link in the
description box and use my code new
rockstars at checkout go to xebiotix.com
new rockstars and get 15 off on your
first order you'll remember thor
ragnarok and thor love and thunder both
include similar opening narrations but
ragnarok revealed thor was talking to a
skeleton in the cage with him and love
and thunder revealed that cork was
talking to the indigorian kids black
panther and chongqi opened with
narrations but those were actually the
voices of njobu telling young killmonger
the history of wakanda and chiang chi's
mother ying li telling him the history
of win woo ms marvel opened with kamala
khan narrating her account of the events
of in-game but that was for her youtube
video really the closest example of this
that we've gotten so far in the mcu has
been one division episode six opened
with billy speaking to camera the way
malcolm does and malcolm in the middle
episode seven an episode titled breaking
the fourth wall features wanda and other
characters giving talking heads
interviews in the style of modern family
that is until the creepiest twist occurs
i don't understand what's happening why
it's all falling apart and why
i can't fix it
do you think maybe this is what you
deserve
what
you're not supposed to talk that
off-screen voice was catherine han's
voice modulated to a lower pitch before
as the closing song revealed it was
agatha all along in the director's chair
presumably also who billy was talking to
in episode six again the breaking of the
fourth wall had an audience in the
reality of the story so when it comes to
she-hulk this leaves us with two
possibilities a she-hulk could actually
be talking to someone off-screen who
will be revealed or b she-hulk could
just be talking to herself and this
could just be a new cosmic reality rule
that's being opened up in the mcu much
like that subtle terrifying moment the
scarlet witch looked at us and
multiverse of madness something that
should never ever happen despite the
rooster brothers nephew doing it in
endgame in a scene with well what do you
know hulk again
either way it's hard not to see
she-hulk's breaking to the fourth wall
as part of a reality shattering trend
that started with wanda in one division
and will lead inevitably to deadpool
setting the table so that deadpool's
meta humor makes sense in this reality
maybe even narratively justifying why
these two characters do it and before
you say i am forcing deadpool into this
titania actor jamila jamil told
comicbook.com that she expects titania
to return into thunderbolts and she
name-dropped deadpool ryan reynolds and
if you've been paying attention to
various statements from actors in recent
weeks it's almost as if a lot of these
folks were told stuff ahead of d23 and
just have an interesting way of dropping
this stuff in interviews also maybe i'm
reading into it but that car crash that
causes jen's power up features a slow
motion freefall with floating odds and
ends visually super similar to the
opening shot of the 2016 deadpool film
so is she hulk in each of these meta
moments talking to deadpool and deadpool
to her probably not but both of these
characters as part of their powers have
an ability to break reality and an
inherent loneliness that gives them a
need to tell their story to someone the
way wanda's loneliness led her to break
reality so who is that audience maybe
the watcher whom thor 11 thunder
confirmed exists in some live-action
form or for that matter lady death
deadpool's lover from the comics who
also must exist in live-action form kang
who scripted all of this and is
she-hulk's destined foe in kang dynasty
according to mark ruffalo or could
marvel studios blow our minds by
suggesting that the disembodied one
above all of the marvel hierarchy are
the viewers who dictate so much of this
reality with our speculation our fan art
and our head cannon as we watch she-hulk
this season just know that according to
marvel's own rules so far jen walters
must be talking to someone and every
time she does it it makes the mcu a
looser place for the merc with the mouth
to slide in next to her and steal the
mic wait a minute you mean to tell me
knight lawyer can see you too what is
she even telling you does attorney
client privilege extend to disney plus
subscribers i hope so let me know your
thoughts on this theory follow me on
instagram and on twitter at eavos
subscribe to new rockstars for more of
my overall analysis thank you so much
for watching bye
[Music]
you